yeah that's right I got this mitten and
lootcrate then they were recalled
because I guess they don't protect
against heat too well and I was like no
no I want to use that thing in my
thumbnail from my Avengers infinity war
review right Marvel has their plan I
have mine spend years coming nailed it
[Music]
Avengers infinity war gonna call them
your mind right now this is a spoiler
free review no spoilers here if I say
something that you think is a spoiler
trust me it's not or on the flip side of
that coin if my review comes across as
vague I'm simply trying to avoid
spoilers more than usual people have
waited a decade for this movie so I'm
gonna go ahead and be a little um a
little more hyper aware so there it is I
have a spoiler video that will come out
this weekend until then spoilers afraid
here we go so Avengers infinity war is
the newest Avengers movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it has officially
been 10 years coming oh really six years
coming since we were shown fan us at the
end of the Avengers came out 2012
2018 - closer to say like 10 years for
the MCU you can argue it's all built to
this big baddie Thanos is on the hunt
for the Infinity stones and the Avengers
find out about that and some people who
were not Avengers that maybe guardians
of a galaxy
when does they'll find out about it so
they all have to stop it and that is
basically what you need to know for the
Zetas I want to gush about Thanos right
off the bat can I go see about the nose
right off the bat I feel like I'm not
supposed to I should save that till
later but holy [ __ ] Santos is such a
good villain CGI on Thanos is on point
even the facial tics just small facial
movements that people have when they
talk or react but it's not just the
performance Josh Brolin Gibbs it's not
just the intensity he really is a staple
of how to do a great villain that's
something the MCU has been severely
lacking in if you think of the weakest
part of most movies in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's usually a weak
villain the analyst breaks that yes
granted we have had many years of Thanos
build-up but I'm talking about just what
you see of him in this movie that's what
makes him a great villain it's the
development it's his character he's not
just bad guy forsake a bad guy this
movie does what a movie needs to do to
make a great villain is that the villain
truly believes what he is doing is the
best thing possible for existence that's
right generally you think of big bad
[ __ ] in the real world or fiction
every villain believes they are the hero
of their story that was a very important
thing I was looking for in this movie
this movie had it they just completely
did Thanos right in this movie the
development for Thanos makes the
development for Loki look like the
development of whoever that is I forget
and the action was cleaned up to the
Russos in their MCU movies for the
action sequences I noticed sometimes is
that shaky-cam but I noticed they
minimize that in here like the action
sequence at the end that you've seen in
the trailers you know it's like a big
crowd of of things coming towards a
bunch of people
pales in comparison I feel like that's
an action sequence that happens for the
sake of action sequence or a couple of
other action sequences one fight in
particular I'm like this is amazing
those like they were like that's so
amazing what to do with those I don't
know let's just have bugs but in the
true great action movies of modern time
I feel like the action sequences should
be a byproduct of a movie that's great
anyway this movie does pull that off
sometimes if some of the drama was going
on some things I was really invested in
I really bought it other times I was
like don't buy it as much as the other
stuff and I know I was really supposed
to I feel like it's what happens when
you have a bunch of different directors
directing a bunch of different movies
that take place in the same universe
these directions want to concentrate on
this so when the payoffs supposed to
happen here doesn't really happen as
much because these two directors just
kind of see the world differently
because people see the world differently
they see entertainment differently
whether it's a consumer of entertainment
or someone who's making entertainment
they're going to concentrate on
different things and that gives
different tonal shifts and the being
vague I know I'm supposed to be and the
cast is so bad I mean the cast is going
to be big we know it's gonna be better I
mean it needs to be bigger this is the
three phases of Marvel movies leading up
to this it wasn't big that would be a
huge problem it just so happens the cast
is so big maybe there is a character you
want to see have their shine it's just
they can't there's too many people one
character in particular I'm like maybe
they should have been in the forefront
more but they weren't because it wasn't
their movie there's more going on in one
person but it does feel like some
characters were used well others were
support characters and then some other
characters just kind of in the movie
because the contract said some there's a
lot of jump around that happens because
there is a lot happening there are a lot
of locations where stones may or may not
be with characters that may or may not
be on earth at this point a lot of
locations a lot of people so it's not
like everybody who's been in an MCU
movie to this point or just hanging out
on earth and they're all at the same
place any given time know there are like
three different groups doing different
things on the name of stopping Thanos
but that makes for a lot of jumping
around granted given the scenario this
much build up coming to this with this
many characters they pull it off quite
well so sometimes just a little
imperfect but I will also give props to
the fact that the tone does change based
on who's on screen like when you see the
guardians of the galaxy it feels more
like guardians of the galaxy oh that was
great that's very important nothing in
this movie feels like thor ragnarok
though so that's that's kind of still an
anomaly guys in the end Avengers
infinity war was a long time coming a
decade of set up for an epic payoff that
I personally dug
just fanservice doesn't throw fanservice
at you for the sake of fanservice there
are a couple moments for sure and a
couple of moments in particular some
straight-up heroic moments I got me the
goosebumps I was like ooh this movie is
great I thoroughly enjoyed it I will say
Avengers infinity war is worth watching
and worth buying on blu-ray and though
this review is up I'm still doing
Stardust reactions for the MCU movies
leading up to it alright so got a war
came out and I got a little behind play
the game for 14 hours yesterday that's
not healthy what closet my legs for sure
like 75% of that so my Avengers infinity
war spoiler video coming this weekend
gonna do a video on the venom trailer
that came out also so much to do so
little time bye so Avengers infinity war
have you seen it what did you think
about it or if you haven't because it is
Tuesday are you looking forward to it
and how much whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]